so look whether you're a leader of a
company you're the ceo you're the
founder you're somebody that's running
an organization or you have a family you
got wife you got a husband you got kids
siblings it is time for an emergency
meeting to discuss three different
things with everybody involved today's
message is sponsored by better help i'm
a big fan of what these folks who had
better health for a couple reasons so
let me share with you number one when
you're an entrepreneur you're a
salesperson you're a doer a lot of times
you're alone you're by yourself and
you're coming home late at night you had
a bad day maybe you lost a sale maybe
you lost the deal and you're frustrated
you can't call your mom you can't call
your wife you can't talk to anybody and
you're kind of alone but you got to talk
to somebody when i was building my
company for many many years i had
therapists that i would go see that was
specific to entrepreneurship and
business and i would go on a weekly
basis it was the best release i had to
talk to somebody about what i was going
through because i couldn't do with my
wife or my family so at betterhelp.com
you have 20 000 licensed therapists to
choose from you go in there you fill out
your information within 48 hours they
get back to you you want a male you want
a female it doesn't matter you have many
different options and then from there
you can start working with somebody face
to face discreet by yourself on your
phone no matter what part of the world
you're in they'll have that accessible
to you go to betterhelp.com forward
slash valuetainment to get a 10 discount
your first 30 days again better
help help
dot com forward slash valuetainment to
get a 10 discount we're gonna put the
link below in the description by the way
if this gets you thinking and you get
value from it give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so let's get
right into it uh these are uncertain
times when times are uncertain it
doesn't mean it's bad it doesn't mean
it's good it's just uncertain people
don't know what's going to be happening
uncertainty creates anxiety uncertainty
creates worry creates stress creates
unnecessary concerns that people are
imagining we self sabotage and sometimes
we are worried and we don't share our
fears with other people but a leader
comes out and said listen guys
here's what's going on this is what i
think we need to be doing i'll never
forget when the covid situation happened
i came back stayed at the office and we
did a zoom with a bunch of our
executives to see how they were feeling
i'll never forget the zoom
our ladies who would always wear makeup
had no makeup on and i've never seen no
makeup on specifically on a zoom and i
saw guys who were like this on the
camera not showing their whole face
because everybody thought this pandemic
was going to be like contagion the movie
it was the end of the world we were all
afraid we were uncertain and everybody
needed somebody to bring that's that
level of fear down instead of just
spiking up because every time you turn
on the news this many people died oh my
god this many people oh my god so we
kind of needed more of this your family
today needs a little bit of this so now
three things everybody's got to do
musk said this but i'm going to explain
it to you in a completely different way
our job as leaders is to constantly make
predictions
a visionary is predicting what the
future is going to be looking like now a
visionary doesn't have to be steve jobs
i believe everybody in a family is a
visionary so for example a bad parent
who's insecure will say things like
you'll never amount to anything you're a
visionary but you just told your kid
you're never going to amount to anything
that is a form of a vision you're
casting to your son or your daughter
that son or daughter is going to believe
that it's going to say
man mom told me i'll never amount to
anything
that's a prediction
and that we feel it here right versus
if you apply these habits if you stay
away from this if you read this if you
work like this future looks very bright
for you okay so i have to do something
but future looks bright absolutely great
you as a family i set my family down
and i said here's what i think is going
to happen the marketplace and this is
what we need to be ready for right now
one protection-wise we need to be ready
on protection what does protection mean
where you live how do you come home
security driving the other day we had
one of our girls uh here she's driving a
guy bumps into the car she gets out of
the car the guy gets out shoves her on
the floor takes the money and runs off
if you're driving by yourself today and
somebody bumps into the car don't get
out of the car stay in the car
call the uh somebody on the phone that
you're talking to while they're coming
to the door so somebody else is
witnessing it because this is a weapon
but you got to be prepared for it kids
when this happens do this hey honey when
this happens do this dad when you're
going out there and do this everybody
has to be somewhat prepared for today
now it's going to be all right but this
is what we need to be financially here's
what we need to be thinking about
spending in this area opportunity in
this area doing this doing that you need
to have that conversation but you need
to make predictions today the prediction
is here's what i predict is going to
happen to the economy here's what i
predict is going to happen to the
marketplace here's what i predict is
going to happen to crime here's what i
predict is going to happen to this so
hey my 17 year old son i don't have a 17
year old son i got a 10 year old son
right now but hey 17 year old son
probably not a good time to be partying
too late right now just telling you
right now people are desperate they're
worried they're stressed out be a little
bit more cautious today stay a little
bit come home a little bit earlier today
than before
why it's bad times okay
when i'm saying when this thing gets a
little bit even deeper and it's gonna be
a little bit more i'm gonna probably say
those are some of the predictions i'm
saying let's just be a little bit more
careful on where we're gonna be and
surroundings we're gonna be financially
predictions honey here's what we're
going to be doing business-wise
prediction here's more opportunities for
our company here's our threat you got to
do a swot analysis here's a strength
weakness opportunity threat you got to
look at in this economy if the market
really does take a hit if real estate
does really take a hit here's our
strength here's our weakness here's our
opportunity here's our threat okay you
gotta talk about that stuff today and
make your bold prediction and here's
where we're going to win and here's what
we're gonna advance as a family and
here's what we're going to do your
prediction to your girlfriend if you're
got a girlfriend to your family if you
got wife and kids into your company if
you're leading an organization yourself
you make the prediction after you make
the prediction then you say here's how
we're going to be prepared for it so
this is my prediction i think this is
what's going to happen here's how we're
going to be prepared for it we're going
to be ready for this in this area we're
going to be ready for that in that area
if this happens to the market we're
going to move this if that happens to
the market we're going to use this
technology we're going to use this sale
we're going to sell this product we're
going to create this protection you know
if clients start doing a lot of
fraudulent stuff nowadays you got to be
careful because when people are
desperate in sales specifically when
market takes a hit and people are
desperate fraudulency you know
fraudulent activities goes up so you
need better cyber you need better
compliance again predict prepare and
then the next part is what you got to
make it through persevere
you know it's just survival of the
fittest the best people make it in
business those that are prepared for
those that are sitting there saying i'm
the most prepared i kind of saw this
coming and i was okay with it what is
not the right thing to do
is if you're like ah come on give me a
break no problem but that's a form of a
prediction
you're saying it's not that big of a
deal it's gonna be all right that you
are predicting yeah we're going to be
okay your preparation is let's not do
anything different we're going to be all
right okay you're going to persevere by
the way
there's a 10 chance you're right but
there's a 90 chance you're wrong okay
and i don't like those chances i like it
to be there's a 90 90 chance you're
right but there's a 10 chance you're
wrong i like those odds so
if you're somebody that's kind of like
yeah whatever maybe take a little time
out
call an emergency meeting with yourself
map it out then go talk to your family
your kids your dad your mom everybody
and then go talk to your organization as
well with your predictions not imposing
fear not imposing like scary times into
the world because everything's going to
be fine if you are fully prepared and
you're able to persevere as a family
having said that give it a thumbs up if
you got a lot of value out of this video
and subscribe to the channel and
everything's about next moves right now
i'm going to give you two crazy things
to do number one go watch the video
grandmaster i shot this video got a few
million views i gave the message to like
a thousand people in l.a i think was
long beach or this is actually a perfect
time to go buy the book i've never done
this before go buy the book your next
five moves because today it's all about
what your next five moves are going to
be if you haven't read it yet or if you
haven't listened to the audible yet go
buy the book read it listen to it
there's never been a more important time
for you to be clear about your next 5 10
15 moves take care everybody bye